[Music]
it was a moment of simple courtesy that
turned into a harrowing ordeal in
Florida a woman working out in the gym
of her apartment complex took a break to
let someone in what happened next became
a test of all her mental and physical
strength correspondent Michael George is
here with the story Michael this was
just absolutely terrifying to see good
morning yeah Dana this is scary stuff
nationally Alma was all alone in a Tampa
gym last month when a man attacked she
fought back and survived and now she
wants to share her story to help other
women we do want to warn you this video
is disturbing
it's around 10 p.m 24 year old Nasha Lee
Alma is working out alone in her
apartment complex's gym when she sees a
man at the door she says she'd seen him
in the gym before I bust a man and he
came inside my thought process it was
just another Jew coming in to work out
so I didn't mind I didn't think of
anything out of that a few minutes pass
then he approaches and tries to grab her
I said bro what the f are you doing get
away from me stop trying to touch me she
desperately tries to dial 9-1-1 while
avoiding the attacker she runs but he's
right behind her he tries to throw her
to the ground but nationally Fights Back
repeatedly hitting him with her cell
phone when it was happening I actually
had no fear I am a bodybuilder and I'm
actually pretty strong so in my mind he
was kind of equal to me I didn't see him
as bigger even as she's pinned down she
keeps fighting pulling his beard hair I
keep going if I keep pushing I keep
fighting he's gonna stop he's going to
let go he finally does let go and
nationally runs off the Hillsborough
County Sheriff's Office says the next
day they arrested 25 year old Xavier
Thomas Jones nationally says she's
speaking out in the hopes it helps
others my advice would be to never give
up my parents always told me in life to
never give on anything and that's one
thing I always kept to my mind when I
was fighting him he showed him that you
are strong that you are one that you're
able to fight back and survive this and
get out of the situation I believe it's
possible because at the end of the video
you can see him getting tired because
the more fight you put the more they
don't they want to give up and just stop
and Thomas Jones is facing charges of
sexual battery false imprisonment and
kidnapping guys talk about bravery and
courage she's fearless and thank
goodness she's okay yeah always be aware
and just always be aware terrifying and
good the cameras were there yeah this
happened in her apartment yes and she's
seen them there before right and that's
why she thought it was safe to let him
in because this is somebody that she had
seen and assumed was a residence and I
love that she said like just keep
fighting like just keep fighting
fighting like a girl that she was yeah
thank you Michael